.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Mit Tieren sprechen - geht das?
Viele halten es für unmöglich,
andere schwärmen von Pferdeflüsterern
und Tierkommunikatoren.
Meine Geschichte beginnt damit,
dass ich einfach verstehen wollte,
was in meiner Hündin Bina vorgeht.
Dass ich mit Tieren arbeite,
liegt sicher daran,
dass ich selbst Tiere hatte
und merkte,
dass ich sie auch behandeln konnte.
Das bewirkt etwas,
auch bei kleinen Tieren.
Das hat mich fasziniert.
Mich interessiert einfach alles, was
einen Körper hat und lebendig ist,
was man berühren kann und bei dem
man mit Energie arbeiten kann.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Wir haben uns
von der Tierwelt abgetrennt,
weil wir die Fähigkeit zu fühlen
verloren und angefangen haben,
alles zu intellektualisieren.
Wir gingen von da nach da.
Es ist nicht weit, aber die Reise
zurück dahin ist lang.
Das ist für mich ein sehr
ästhetisches, sensibles Tier.
Nicht viele können mit Pferden
richtig sensibel
und kommunikativ umgehen.
Das hat mich gereizt.
Ich muss sagen, früher
war es noch eher so als heute.
Wir sind auf einem guten Weg,
das Pferd besser zu verstehen.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Die Kleine vorne ist Bina als Welpe.
Ich habe sie während Dreharbeiten
auf einer Alp im Muotathal
aufwachsen sehen.
Sie wuchs mir ans Herz, aber
ich wollte nie einen Hund haben -
dafür schien in meinem Leben
kein Platz zu sein.
Ich hatte auch
keine Erfahrung mit Hunden.
Als sie ein halbes Jahr alt war,
besuchte ich sie
auf dem Bauernhof im Tal.
Der Besitzer meinte,
er müsse sie bald einschläfern.
Sie würde regelmässig erbrechen.
Zu meiner eigenen Verwunderung
sagte ich:
"Ich nehme sie -
genau so, wie sie ist."
Und dann waren wir beide überfordert.
Sie war hyperaktiv, leicht erregbar
und bellte an der Leine
alle Hunde an.
Das Erbrechen blieb,
besonders nach dem Bellen.
Tierärzte konnten nur wenig helfen.
Die Diagnose war: stark erweiterte,
teilgelähmte Speiseröhre.
Seltsamerweise gab es Tage,
an denen sie keine Probleme hatte,
und an anderen musste sie
selbst im Schlaf erbrechen.
Ich konnte kein Muster erkennen.
Sorgen, Schlafmangel
und Hilflosigkeit nahmen zu.
Niemand konnte wirklich helfen.
Damals hörte ich zum ersten Mal von
Tierkommunikation und von Menschen,
die angeblich
mit Tieren reden können.
Neugierig beschloss ich,
das Phänomen zu ergründen.
Ich wollte alles ausprobieren,
um Bina zu helfen,
und begann eine Reise
in die Welt der Tierflüsterer.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Als Erste traf ich
Körpertherapeutin Monika Obi.
Sie kommuniziert physisch
und energetisch mit Tieren.
Ich habe verschiedene Dinge gelernt.
Ich arbeite mit Shiatsu,
mit der Atmung und mit Bewegung.
Ich schaue,
wie die Energie im Körper ist.
Wo ist eher ein Energiestau
und wo ist zu wenig Energie?
Wo herrscht Leere?
An welchen Punkten,
an welchen Körperstellen ist das?
Oder wenn wir von Shiatsu sprechen:
in welchen Meridianen?
Das sind Energiebahnen.
Und dann gleiche ich das aus.
Du spürst das, was?
Mit Hunden arbeite ich immer
in einem Dreieck mit dem Besitzer.
Hunde sind so auf ihre Besitzer
fixiert und so symbiotisch,
dass es für mich relativ schwierig
ist, nur mit dem Tier zu arbeiten.
Und wenn ich mit einem Tier arbeite,
stehe ich oft unter Beobachtung.
Man muss lernen, das zu ignorieren.
(Frau) Sie ist jetzt neun
und wir sind froh,
dass sie so alt werden durfte.
Sie hat
eine böse Geschichte hinter sich.
Mit gut einem Jahr
hatte sie autoimmune Meningitis.
Das ist für Hunde
eine schwere Erkrankung.
Sie war auch recht lange
im Tierspital Zürich.
Danach hiess es,
sie müsse ewig Kortison nehmen
und habe eine Lebenserwartung
von etwa sechs Monaten.
Eine junge Frau
erzählte mir von Tiershiatsu.
Sie empfahl mir Monika Obi.
Wir haben es ausprobiert,
das Problem ist gelöst.
Shiva
braucht keine Schmerzmittel mehr,
auch wenn sie sich angestrengt hat
und nach dem Spazieren
erschöpft ist.
Beim Shiatsu bin ich
auf verschiedenen Ebenen offen.
Und ich bin mit verschiedenen
Wahrnehmungsfähigkeiten offen.
Es wird nicht immer derselbe Sinn
angesprochen, wenn ich arbeite.
Das kann ich nicht vorhersagen.
Ich bin einfach ruhig, präsent und
offen gegenüber dem, was ich sehe.
Es kann sein,
dass ich innerlich ein Bild sehe,
dass ich über die Hände
irgendwo hingeführt werde
und dann die Hände anfangen,
zu wirbeln.
Oder ich muss an einer Leere
bleiben, damit viel Liebe fliesst.
Vielleicht spüre ich
einen Schmerz in den Händen.
Ganz loslassen.
Lass los.
Ja.
Meist merke ich
während der Behandlung,
dass das Tier ganz da ist.
Dann kann ich dieses Wesen plötzlich
in seiner ganzen Grösse sehen -
nicht nur als Tier,
sondern auch als geistiges Wesen.
Das ist immer mit viel Liebe
und Respekt verbunden.
Es ist einer der schönen Momente
im Tiershiatsu,
wenn wir uns wirklich
auf Augenhöhe begegnen können.
Allez, Walze.
Die Erfolge der Therapeutin
machten mich neugierig.
Walze. Komm, Kashmir.
Ich wollte mehr
über die Kommunikation
zwischen Mensch und Tier erfahren
und besuchte jenen Mann,
dessen Pferdenummern
mich schon als Kind fasziniert haben.
Fredy Knie Jr.
Voilà.
So ist gut.
* Applaus *
Prima.
Ho! Halt. Allez.
* Er schnalzt mit der Zunge. *
Schon als Kind habe ich
mit allen Tieren gearbeitet.
Die wichtigste Lektion
ist Selbstbeherrschung.
Wenn man mit Pferden umgehen will,
muss man
sich selbst beherrschen können.
Das ist auch
im menschlichen Umgang sehr wichtig.
Aber ich finde auch, dass man
ein Tier nicht vermenschlichen darf.
Ein Tier denkt nicht wie ein Mensch.
Wir müssen lernen,
wie das Tier zu denken,
wenn wir mit ihm arbeiten wollen.
Wenn das Tier etwas nicht tut,
dann nicht, weil es keine Lust hat,
sondern es hat nicht verstanden.
Beim Pferd muss man auf Tricks
zurückgreifen und sich fragen,
wie man es ihm plausibel macht.
Und es natürlich belohnen,
bis es merkt, was man will.
Malak. Malak.
Malak, Kopf. Kopf. Ja.
Brav. Good boys. Allez.
* Schnalzen *
Partez.
Meine Methode basiert auf gegen-
seitigem Vertrauen, Gestik, Stimme.
Ich zeige mit der Peitsche.
Das ist mein verlängerter Arm.
Ich kann damit das Pferd anfassen.
Es darf nicht erschrecken.
Die Peitsche dient nicht dazu,
Schmerz zuzufügen,
sondern Zeichen zu geben.
Das will ich auch
den Jungen weitergeben.
Wie baue ich
gegenseitiges Vertrauen auf,
damit es mir und dem Pferd
Freude bereitet?
Aufpassen. Allez.
* Er schnalzt mehrmals langsam. *
Allez, hopp.
Hey, hey, hey.
Allez, hopp!
So, brav.
* Applaus *
Ja, down.
Seine Fähigkeiten gibt er an seinen
Schwiegersohn Maycol Errani weiter.
Jedes Pferd hat wie ein Mensch
seinen eigenen Charakter.
Es liegt an uns, die beste Methode
für ein bestimmtes Pferd zu finden.
Fredy sagt immer:
"Die Pferde wollen nichts von uns,
wir wollen etwas von ihnen."
Wir machen den ersten Schritt
und bringen ihnen bei,
dass alles in Ordnung ist und alles
in Ruhe und mit Liebe gemacht wird.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Bei meinen Recherchen
stiess ich auf erstaunliche Bilder
eines gewissen James French.
Tiere legen sich in seiner Gegenwart
einfach hin und entspannen sich.
Zusammen mit
seiner Partnerin Shelley Slingo
hilft er Tieren, Vertrauen zu finden.
Er trainierte Jungpferde
in der Pferdeindustrie,
bevor er Reiki-Heiler
und Tierkommunikator wurde.
Daraus entwickelte er
seine Trust Technique.
Ich besuchte ihn in England
auf der Mane Chance Sanctuary,
wo er
traumatisierte Pferde behandelt.
Das ist Millie.
Sie hat
eine interessante Geschichte.
Sie kam
mit einem anderen Pferd hierher.
Die beiden mussten in einer Herde
von 200 Pferden bestehen.
Diese Herde von 200 Pferden
war am Verhungern.
Auf dem Feld lagen tote Pferde.
Knochen von toten Pferden.
Sie konnte kaum
auf ihren Hinterbeinen gehen,
als sie hier ankam.
Sie hatte eine
sehr breite Haltung beim Gehen.
Ihr Rücken schmerzte sie so,
dass man ihn nicht berühren konnte.
Ich glaube,
wenn Pferde am Verhungern sind,
werden sie
einander gegenüber aggressiv,
weil sie ums Überleben kämpfen.
Ich suche mir eine Position.
Bei der Trust Technique
wird alles sehr sanft gemacht.
Man muss sich und seine Gedanken
herunterfahren.
Dann ist auch das Emotionale unten,
und darauf soll sie reagieren.
Wir arbeiten besonders
mit bewusster Achtsamkeit.
Das bedeutet, dass ...
Im Moment hat sie viel Angst
vor dem grossen Mikrofon.
Das ist toll.
Ich wurde gerade ganz präsent,
und ihre Reaktion war:
"Was ist das?"
Wenn ich präsent bliebe,
ohne auf sie zu hören,
wäre es, als würde ich sagen:
"Du bist aufgewühlt,
aber sei einfach ruhig."
Du würdest mir den Grund nennen,
und ich riete dir, ruhig zu bleiben.
Das ergäbe keinen Sinn.
Ich war ganz präsent, sie hob sich,
ich sah sie an und sagte:
"Ja, es ist beängstigend."
Ich hörte ihr zu, obwohl ich
nur für eine Sekunde präsent war.
Jetzt kann ich aber wieder präsent
werden, weil ich zugehört habe.
Ich werde wieder ganz ruhig,
auch körperlich,
und schaue auf einen Punkt.
Eine ganz einfache Meditation.
Wenn sie sich bewegt,
denke ich an sie.
Ich denke,
sie soll langsam ruhiger werden.
Ich erlaube ihr die Interaktion.
Sie beginnt zu lecken -
wohl wieder ein Loslassen.
Nun folgt das Gähnen.
Wir benutzen den Moment der Präsenz
wie eine Pumpe,
mit der alle Furcht und Angst
losgelassen werden kann.
Wenn Furcht und Angst präsent sind,
kann sie mich gar nicht hören,
weil sie in zu hoher Frequenz denkt.
Wenn sie wieder in die Ruhe kommt,
in der ich sie zurückgelassen habe,
muss ich wieder präsent werden.
Ich warte,
bis sie aufhört zu gähnen.
Wenn wir Tier- und Menschen-
kommunikation auf den Grund gehen,
erkennen wir
hinter unserer Körpersprache,
unserem Tonfall und unseren Worten
die Sprache der Gefühle,
die wir verloren haben.
Um sie wiederzugewinnen,
müssen wir sie loslassen.
Wir müssen sein statt zu denken.
Wir müssen viel mehr
mit dem Tier sein,
statt über die Agenda nachzudenken,
oder zu viel zu denken
und besorgt oder frustriert zu sein,
sodass das Tier Angst bekommt.
Oder das Tier hat Angst, und wir
werden frustriert und aufgebracht.
Wir reagieren aufeinander.
Zusammen zu sein
ist die Basis einer Beziehung,
aber auch Basis der Kommunikation
auf einer viel tieferen Ebene.
Kaum zurück bei Bina, versuche ich,
die Ratschläge umzusetzen.
Nicht zu viel denken, präsent sein,
mich in Bina hineinversetzen.
Ich werde etwas ruhiger und sie auch.
Gibt es
wissenschaftliche Erklärungen dafür?
Ich stiess auf den Biologen
Dr. Rupert Sheldrake in London.
Er hat jahrelang Quantenphysik
und Telepathie erforscht
und zahlreiche Bücher geschrieben -
u.a. "Der siebte Sinn der Tiere".
Rupert Sheldrake hat über 5'000
Geschichten von Tieren ausgewertet,
deren Besitzer merkten, dass
die Tiere ihre Absichten kannten.
Telepathie
heisst fühlen über Distanz.
Tele wie in Television
heisst entfernt.
Pathie heisst fühlen,
wie in Sympathie, Empathie.
Tiere scheinen
die Fähigkeit zu besitzen,
die Absichten ihres Besitzers
wahrzunehmen.
Tiere können menschliche Absichten
besser wahrnehmen
als Menschen
die Absichten von Tieren.
Aber Telepathie
zwischen Menschen und Tieren
kann beidseitig funktionieren.
Ich forschte viel
bezüglich Hunden und Katzen,
die wissen,
wann ihr Besitzer nach Hause kommt.
Diese Tiere
warten an der Tür oder am Fenster,
wenn ihr Besitzer
auf dem Heimweg ist.
Die Menschen zu Hause wissen
durch das Verhalten der Tiere,
dass die Person kommt.
Natürlich kann das in manchen Fällen
aufgrund einer Regelmässigkeit sein,
oder weil die Tiere die Person oder
einen bekannten Automotor hören.
Wir haben jedoch festgestellt,
dass sensible Hunde die Ankunft
der Person selbst dann spüren,
wenn sie noch 8 km entfernt ist
oder zu einer unüblichen Zeit
nach Hause kommt.
Die einzige Erklärung dafür
scheint Telepathie zu sein.
Ich hielt einmal einen Vortrag
über meine Arbeit
mit Telepathie und Hunden in Zürich.
Im Publikum sass ein Bauer.
Während der Fragerunde sagte er:
"Dr. Sheldrake,
wieso verschwenden Sie Ihre Zeit
auf den Beweis von etwas,
was jeder schon weiss?"
Für viele Hundebesitzer ist klar,
dass ihre Hunde ihre Gedanken
und Absichten wahrnehmen können,
ihre Launen registrieren
und telepathisch sind.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Auch für mich war klar, dass Bina
spürt, was ich denke und fühle.
Und umgekehrt?
Wie kann ich klarer wahrnehmen,
was in Bina vorgeht?
Hat James einen Tipp,
wie ich besser zuhören kann?
Die Tiere,
mit denen Shelley und ich arbeiten,
sind manchmal schockiert,
wenn wir ihnen zuhören.
Sie scheinen nicht zu wissen,
dass Menschen das können.
Je mehr man sich
mit einem ruhigen Geist
und der Arbeit
mit Tieren auseinandersetzt,
desto mehr realisiert man,
wie weit weg Menschen sind
und wie sehr sie nicht zuhören.
Es zeigt sich glasklar,
was für eine riesige Lücke
in unserer eigenen Evolution klafft,
bis wir das überbrückt haben.
Menschen ist nicht bewusst, wie
stark der gegenwärtige Moment ist.
Ein Mensch, der bewusst
nichts denkt - das ist pures Sein.
Das passiert normalerweise
kurz vor dem Einschlafen.
Plötzlich einen Raum zu schaffen,
indem man nur ist,
ohne dieses ruhelose Denken,
ist sehr stark.
Ich beruhige ihren Geist nun tiefer.
Das grosse Mikrofon
war sehr beängstigend.
Lasst uns Folgendes tun ...
Ich weiss,
das stört eure Filmarbeit,
aber ich möchte,
dass Thomas näher kommt.
Noch näher.
Wir zeigen ihr
mit friedvollem Geist, wie es geht.
Und stopp.
Meine Aufgabe ist nun, mitzuteilen,
Thomas auf 6 m Distanz
friedlich zu begegnen.
Ich beobachte,
wann sich ihre Aufmerksamkeit regt.
Ihr Kopf bleibt still. Wunderbar.
Komm näher. Stopp.
Jetzt bitte ich sie,
dir gegenüber friedlich zu sein ...
... bei 3,5 m Entfernung.
Sieh dir das an.
Sie will zu dir kommen.
Sie verkleinert den Abstand
zwischen uns.
Sie wendet sich
für dieses Vertrauen zu mir,
weil ich ihr geholfen habe,
ruhig damit umzugehen.
Obwohl sie jetzt sehr mutig ist ...
Mutig ist ganz anders als friedlich.
Mutig heisst, man hat Angst,
tut es aber trotzdem.
Jetzt ist sie sehr mutig.
Ich möchte,
dass sie damit friedvoll ist.
Friedvoll heisst ohne Angst.
Du tust etwas,
ohne denken zu müssen.
Das reicht.
Ich muss nicht tief schlafen.
Es dauert nur
ein paar Sekunden, nicht?
10, 15 Sek.
mit einer starken Wirkung auf sie.
Die bleibt, auch wenn ich nun rede.
Du kannst näher kommen.
Gut gemacht. Das reicht.
Ihr Mut ist nun da.
Sie schnuppert an etwas, vor dem sie
vorhin entsetzliche Angst hatte.
Sieh dir ihre Dankbarkeit
mir gegenüber an.
Ein wenig Frust,
aber auch Dankbarkeit.
Sie kommt nun näher zu mir,
weil ich ihr geholfen habe.
Sie will sich bedanken.
"Ich weiss nicht, wieso du
das getan hast, Papa, aber danke."
"Ich weiss nicht,
wieso ich mich mit dem flauschigen
Teil wohlfühlen soll, aber danke."
* Verzerrte, wirre Gitarrenmusik *
Inspiriert von James übe ich,
bewusst da zu sein.
Das ist offenbar
eine Grundvoraussetzung,
um Tiere gut wahrzunehmen.
Ich hoffe,
dass Bina so mehr Ruhe findet.
Ich fokussiere mit ruhigem Körper
und Geist einen Punkt,
spüre meinen Atem und richte
die innere Aufmerksamkeit auf Bina.
Ich bin erstaunt,
wie schnell sie sich entspannt.
Oder bin eher ich die,
die sich entspannt?
(Monika)
Er hat mich zunächst gelehrt,
meine Angst
vor anderen Hunden abzubauen.
Ich habe gelernt, Hunde zu lesen.
Er hat eine absolute Ruhe -
Tiere allgemein.
Innerlich ausatmen,
mich bei ihm anlehnen zu dürfen
und zu spüren, dass er das mag und
auch braucht - gerade träumt er -,
gibt mir viel.
Bevor ich den Hund hatte,
las ich alles über Hunde.
Ich ging in die Buchhandlung
und zog auch ein Buch
über Tierkommunikation heraus.
Die Idee gefiel mir, aber ich
glaubte nicht alles, was da stand.
Das habe ich inzwischen revidiert,
weil ich es erfahren habe.
Sagst du nichts mehr?
Tierkommunikation zu lernen,
fiel mir recht leicht.
Am Anfang der Ausbildung schaut man
ja, welches der stärkste Kanal ist.
Empfange ich Botschaften
z.B. über Bilder,
die ich beschreiben
oder für mich übersetzen muss?
Oder höre ich z.B. eine Stimme?
Oder weiss ich es einfach
und kann nicht erklären, warum?
Es gibt auch andere Kanäle.
Da merkte ich, dass diese Kanäle
durch das viele Shiatsu,
das ich ja schon immer mache,
schon ziemlich weit geöffnet sind.
Dieses Angebot, Tierkommunikation
fürs Shiatsu zu betreiben,
habe ich noch nicht so lange.
Die Medialität habe ich aber
eigentlich schon lange.
V.a. mit Menschen.
Wenn ich mit Menschen arbeite,
erhalte ich oft Botschaften.
Die Tierkommunikation
kostet mich v.a. Mut.
Wenn ich Bilder empfange
oder etwas höre
und das einer fremden Person
gegenüber einfach ausspreche,
kostet mich das Mut, weil ich das
noch nicht so viel gemacht habe
wie über die Hände.
Wenn ich bei meinem Gegenüber
Erstaunen sehe oder höre ...
Wenn jemand zum ersten Mal da ist
und ich vor dem Shiatsu
Tierkommunikation mache,
und dann verhält sich das Tier,
wie ich gesagt habe,
gibt mir das Sicherheit
für ein nächstes Mal.
So gesehen braucht das viel Übung
für mein Selbstvertrauen.
Tierkommunikation
wende ich sonst bei meinem Hund an,
wenn er irgendein Problem hat.
Oder wenn ich in die Ferien fahre
und ganz sicher sein will,
wem ich ihn geben kann,
was er braucht oder wie es ihm geht.
Dann mache ich das.
Monika kann dank ihrer Verbindung
und Medialität mit Tieren reden.
Sie empfängt Bilder und Botschaften.
Wie kommuniziert James mit Tieren?
Tierkommunikation
ist ein grosser Schritt.
Das ist nicht für jedermann,
weil sich viele abwenden und sagen,
das sei Unsinn.
Wenn wir vor der Kamera
eine Kommunikation umsetzen würden,
würde das sehr von der Person
abhängen, die das Tier kennt.
Man könnte sagen,
dass alles nur inszeniert ist.
Eine unserer Bestrebungen ist,
etwas zu bewirken.
Wir wollen es zeigen.
Wenn wir Pferde dazu bewegen,
sich hinzulegen und zu schlafen,
kann man kaum sagen,
man glaube es nicht,
weil man das sonst kaum sieht.
Man sieht, dass etwas passiert.
Wir Menschen müssen manchmal
etwas sehen, um es zu fühlen.
Am Anfang hiess die Trust Technique
praktische Tierkommunikation.
Es ging um den praktischen Aspekt,
ein körperliches Wiederkommen,
nicht nur um Wahrnehmung
und die Erklärung von Gefühlen.
Es gab eine sichtbare Reaktion.
Daraus entstand die Trust Technique.
Die Trust Technique
basiert auf den Konzepten der
Tiefenheilung und Tierkommunikation.
Sie anerkennt,
dass wir Gefühle teilen.
Die Tiere reagieren stark auf unser
Befinden in ihrer Gesellschaft.
Und wir reagieren stark
auf das Befinden eines Tieres,
besonders wenn es aufgebracht ist.
Wenn wir nicht reagieren,
sondern uns in einen meditativen
Zustand der Achtsamkeit begeben,
reagieren Tiere auch darauf.
Sie hören auf zu denken.
Wenn man mit einem geretteten Pferd,
das Menschen nicht traut,
auf einer Ebene arbeitet,
in der es sich schlafen legt,
lernt es zu vertrauen. So wirkt es.
Früher konnten sie
Menschen nicht trauen,
wenn sie
aus einem tiefen Schlaf erwachten.
Nun erfahren sie etwas ganz anderes.
Sie müssen das eine loslassen.
Wenn wir es richtig anstellen,
lassen sie ihre Vergangenheit los
und vertrauen.
Meine Geschichte beginnt früh.
Meine Familie
erlitt mit dem Tod meiner Schwester
eine grosse Tragödie,
als ich zwei war.
Meine Eltern trennten sich deswegen.
Ein nicht sehr angenehmer Stiefvater
kam in mein Leben.
Ich hatte als kleines Kind
mind. sieben Hunde, drei Pferde
und Schafe um mich herum.
Ich war umgeben von Tieren.
Meine Umgebung
war nicht gesund und nicht sicher.
Aber ich fühlte mich
dank der Unterstützung vieler Tiere
immer sicher.
Sie taten, was wir nun den Tieren
und ihren Menschen geben:
Sie hielten mich ruhig.
Wenn ich sehr aufgewühlt war
und meine Gedanken rasten,
waren sie immer bei mir.
In meiner Kindheit gab es keinen
Moment ohne Hund an meiner Seite.
Sie kümmerten sich immer um mich.
Der tragische Anfang meines Lebens
war ein Glück,
weil ich so meine Erkenntnisse
über die Beziehung zu Tieren gewann.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Hey.
* Er schnalzt mit der Zunge. *
Hier, komm. Ho, ho, ho!
Hier, auf. Hier. Ho, stopp!
Bravo. Good boy.
Das war sehr gut.
Jawohl. Ja, sehr gut. Ja.
Das Wichtigste ist der Respekt.
Ohne Respekt funktioniert es nicht.
Wenn du dich eingibst, kannst du
mit dem Pferd alles erreichen.
Dieses Tier
bringt grosse Zufriedenheit.
Allez, vorwärts. Volte - hepp!
Volte, allez.
* Schnalzen *
Sehr gut, bravo. Komm zu mir, hier.
Sehr gut. Allez.
Natürlich
musst du grosse Leidenschaft haben
und die Arbeit
mit den Tieren lieben.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Es sind nicht nur
die 10 Min. Vorführung in der Arena.
Es dauert den ganzen Tag.
Wir beginnen um 7 Uhr
und sind bis Mitternacht
ständig in Kontakt mit den Tieren.
Kopf hoch. Kopf hoch, Schatzi.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
In der Arena sind es 10 Sek.,
aber diese 10 Sek.
sind vier bis fünf Jahre Training.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Sehr ... Ho! Sehr gut.
Sehr, sehr gut. Bravo, Schatz.
Es ist die Leidenschaft,
die dich dazu antreibt.
Ohne Leidenschaft und ohne Liebe
zum Tier gelingt diese Arbeit nicht.
Dieses Jahr
haben wir 38 Pferde im Reitstall.
Hermes ist
das aussergewöhnlichste von allen -
bezüglich Charakter und Arbeit,
bezüglich allem.
Sehr intelligent, sehr schlau.
Hermes, hör auf. Pst.
Hier, hier, hier, Hermes.
Wie ihr seht, hat Hermes
einen besonderen Charakter.
Er versteht sich nicht
mit den anderen sieben Friesen,
die wir für diese Spielzeit haben.
Mit keinem.
Ein sehr spezieller Charakter.
Komm jetzt. Komm. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Jawohl. Hoch.
Er hat seinen eigenen Charakter,
seine Art.
Mir gefällt Hermes' Art.
Er ist ein Showman.
So ist fein.
Bravo, Schatz. Sehr gut.
Ich sage Fredy immer,
Hermes fehle nur noch die Sprache.
Wenn er noch sprechen könnte,
wäre er wie ein Mensch.
Die Beziehung
ist wie die zu meinen Brüdern.
Wenn ich mit meinen Brüdern Pizza
essen gehe, kommen sie nicht mit -
das ist der einzige Unterschied.
Okay. Ja, komm, komm.
Ja, hey. Hermes, hier. Komm, komm.
Ho, ho! Langsam, langsam!
Du bist mir einer.
Hier, komm. Hier.
Hier, Hermes. Hier. Hier!
Allez, ho! Hoppa! Ho!
Ab. Okay, ho.
Brav. Good boy, ja.
Bina ist allgemein ruhiger geworden,
aber draussen
ist sie immer noch leicht erregbar.
Ich versuche,
mit ruhigem Geist wahrzunehmen,
was in ihr vorgeht.
Ich plane
eine zweiwöchige Reise ohne Bina.
Ich erkläre ihr die Situation,
um sie darauf vorzubereiten.
Ich werde sie täglich
aus der Ferne kontaktieren
und bin gespannt,
ob unsere Verbindung bestehen bleibt.
(Rupert) Wenn sich Mitglieder einer
Gruppe von den anderen entfernen,
wie Wölfe eines Rudels, wenn die
Erwachsenen auf die Jagd gehen,
sind sie trotz Hunderten
von Kilometern Entfernung
über das Feld ständig verbunden.
Sie spüren,
was mit den anderen passiert.
Das ist eine Art Telepathie
innerhalb der Gruppe.
Dazu gibt es in der Quantenphysik
eine Analogie.
Wenn zwei Partikel zum selben Atom
oder Molekül gehören
und auseinandertreiben,
bleiben sie miteinander verbunden.
Eine Veränderung beim einen
hat eine Wirkung auf das andere.
Man nennt das Quantenverschränkung
oder Quanten-Nichtlokalität.
Ich glaube, das Gleiche
gilt für Menschen und Tiere.
Wenn sie
miteinander verbunden sind -
Mutter und Kind,
Hund und Besitzer -
und dann getrennt werden,
bleibt die Verbindung bestehen.
Sie ist gespannt wie ein Gummiband.
Eine Veränderung beim einen
wird Einfluss auf das andere haben.
* Verzerrte, wirre Gitarrenmusik *
In der Wissenschaft
bedeutet das Wort Feld
die Reichweite von Aktivität.
Ich glaube, Lebewesen verfügen über
ein Feld, das den Körper mitformt.
Gehirne haben Felder, die die
Aktivität des Gehirns mitformen.
Tierrudel haben Felder,
die die Gruppe mitformen.
Einzelne Vögel in einem Schwarm,
die gemeinsam drehen,
ohne aneinanderzustossen,
müssen nicht nur wissen,
wo die anderen Vögel sind,
sondern auch, wohin sie gehen.
Sie müssen ihre Absichten kennen.
Ich glaube, Fischschwärme
können miteinander schwimmen,
ohne aneinanderzustossen,
weil sie sich innerhalb
eines Feldes befinden.
Der Schwarm hat ein Feld.
Die einzelnen Vögel
reagieren auf das Feld der Gruppe.
Ein Magnet
hat ein unsichtbares Feld in sich,
das sich nach aussen ausdehnt.
Die Erde hat ein Gravitationsfeld,
das sich unsichtbar ins All ausdehnt
und den Mond
auf seiner Umlaufbahn hält.
Wenn ich dich anrufen will,
dehnt sich meine Absicht
über das erweiterte Feld
meines Geistes zu dir aus.
Ein unsichtbares Feld wie die
Funkübertragung beim Mobiltelefon.
Du kannst es empfangen
und denkst vielleicht an mich.
Ich denke, es ist ein Feldphänomen,
nicht nur innerhalb des Gehirns.
Es ist viel wissenschaftlicher, die
Evidenz für Telepathie anzuerkennen
und zu versuchen, sie zu erklären,
als ihre Existenz zu ignorieren.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ho. No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no. Warte, warte, warte.
Nein.
Haben Sie schon mal von tele-
pathischer Tierkommunikation gehört?
(Maycol) Oh, nein, nein.
Das ist ein bisschen zu viel.
Telepathisch ist ein bisschen ...
Für mich ist es zu viel.
Aber jeder macht, was er will.
Jawohl, hier. Hermes.
Hier. Ho. Ho.
Sehr gut. Bravo, sehr fein.
(James) Ich glaube,
Begriffe wie Telepathie zu belegen,
ist ein Kampf.
Wir müssen vereinfacht sagen,
was wir damit meinen.
Wenn ich jemandem sage:
"Weisst du, dass du
mit deinen Tieren Gefühle teilst?",
würden sie zu 99 % zustimmen.
Es gibt also einfachere Grundlagen
für den Beweis.
Zurück in Zürich
finde ich Bina in gutem Zustand vor.
Sie war in meiner Abwesenheit
noch nie so unbeschwert.
Unsere Verbindung scheint auch
auf Distanz zu funktionieren.
Vom Alltag eingeholt,
fehlt es mir plötzlich an Ruhe,
Vertrauen und Konzentration.
Ich zweifle an den Botschaften,
die ich wahrnehme,
und denke,
dass ich mir alles einbilde.
Verunsichert besuchen wir Monika.
Ja, komm.
Bina, komm rein.
Super. Hallo, bitte reinspaziert.
Reinspaziert.
Bist du dir nicht sicher?
Ja, komm nur. Komm.
Komm, Bina, komm.
Wie geht's?
* Die Hunde bellen. *
Hallo, hallo, hallo. Hör auf.
Bina, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Bina, komm her. Unter den Tisch.
Ja, sag mal! Nein, Bina, fertig.
Komm her. Mach Pla...
Nein, Bina, hör auf.
Also, wie geht's?
Wir sind selbstbewusst.
Wegen des Erbrechens
war ich mal wieder beim Homöopathen.
Mir scheint,
es geht ihr nicht so gut.
Hat sie heute auch erbrochen?
- Ja.
Oft?
- Nein.
Jetzt war's, weil sie bellen musste.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Es ist die Aufregung.
Es ist ja kein richtiges Erbrechen,
sondern es kommt raus,
was schon hier oben ist.
Und zu allem anderen
hat sie sich gestern noch
an der vorderen linken Wolfskralle
verletzt.
Oh nein.- Es wäre gut,
sie allgemein zu beruhigen.
Damit sie sich nicht so sehr aufregt.
- Ja.
Komm, steh auf. Ja.
Brav. Du bist eine Gute.
Und Endo bleibt dort, ja?
Du kannst dich hinlegen, ja, genau.
Du bist eine Gute.
Da klemmt sie einfach viel zusammen.
Na, Schätzchen?
Du bist doch eigentlich so tough.
Oder doch nicht so? Nur hier vorne?
Machen wir etwas Wellness
für die Muskeln.
Ich arbeite ziemlich daran,
dass das Gewebe
wieder schön verheilt.
Das mache ich mental.
Ich folge dem Verlauf,
wie das Gewebe heilt.
Vorhin habe ich Farbe geschickt.
Es ist halt wirklich wie ein Riss.
So gut hat sie noch nie
stillgehalten, glaube ich.
Das ist ein grosses Zeichen.
Sie will es gut machen
und hat Vertrauen.
Du bist so entspannt, wenn doch so
viele Augen auf dich gerichtet sind.
Sonst gehen Hunde unter den Tisch,
unter ein schützendes Dach,
wenn sie sich entspannen.
Ja, das machst du sehr gut.
Sehr viel Vertrauen.
Während der Behandlung
habe ich von ihr wahrgenommen,
dass sie viel aufpasst.
Sie übernimmt auch Verantwortung,
aber sie kontrolliert auch.
Wenn es nicht so läuft,
wie sie es sich vorstellt,
regt sie das auf.
Das ist bei mir angekommen.
Sie hat einen gewissen Sinn davon,
wie die Dinge sein müssen.
Ich weiss nicht wie,
aus ihrer Sicht.
Bina hat Verspannungen
und regt sich auf,
wenn etwas nicht so ist,
wie sie es gerne hätte.
Das kenne ich auch von mir.
Monikas Behandlung entspannt Bina.
Sie wird selbstbewusster.
Ich möchte von James French
weitere Ratschläge.
Für mich ist Begeisterung
dasselbe wie Aufregung.
Die Gefühlsspannung ist hoch.
Es könnte Angstaggression sein.
Ich sage: Handle ganz normal.
Lass die Reaktion zu.
Wir arbeiten
mit Ruhe, Geduld und Ausdauer.
Ruhe ist das Jetzt.
Geduld ist das Vermögen, das Wesen
sich selbst sein zu lassen.
Keine Bedingungen stellen.
Lass ihr die Begeisterung,
das verrückte Bellen.
Wenn der Hund weg ist,
sag ihr, sie soll Platz machen.
Wenn sie dich nicht hört,
werde ganz präsent
und sag, sie soll Platz machen,
bis sie sich hinlegt.
Wenn du das tust, gibt es irgendwann
keine Reaktion mehr.
Sag ihr im Moment nur,
sie soll friedlich sein.
Das ist
eine wunderbare Kommunikation.
Wenn wir friedlich sind,
ist alles in Ordnung.
Nichts ist mehr ein Problem.
Wir schauen aber nur
auf der Gefühlsebene hin.
Wir anerkennen und akzeptieren sie
und finden Frieden damit.
Das ist loslassen.
Seit ich Bina so akzeptiere,
wie sie ist,
ist sie selbstbewusster geworden und
bellt und erbricht deutlich weniger.
Ich selbst
bin ruhiger und klarer geworden.
Bina ist weiser und souveräner,
als mir bewusst war.
Ich habe sie mit meinen Sorgen
um ihr Wohlbefinden
und meinem Stress unnötig belastet.
* Verträumte Musik *
(Maycol) Dieses Jahr präsentiere ich
eine Nummer mit 28 Pferden -
verschiedene Rassen, verschiedene
Farben, verschiedene Charaktere.
Fredy unterstützt mich immer.
Zusammen mit ihm ist es mir
gelungen, sie alle zusammenzuhalten.
Ich kann nicht
alle Pferde kontrollieren.
Dafür sind 28 Pferde auf einmal
zu viele.
Mit unserem neuen System
erzielen wir unglaubliche Resultate.
Das bedeutet,
dass unsere Arbeit richtig ist.
Wenn alle harmonieren, bedeutet das,
dass unsere Arbeit
richtig und korrekt ist.
* Verträumte Musik *
Wie die Tierlehrer des Circus Knie
es schaffen,
dass ihre Pferde
solche Leistungen vollbringen,
bleibt mir ein Geheimnis.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmelodie *
Die wissenschaftliche Forschung
zeigt,
dass Telepathie zwischen Menschen
und zwischen Mensch und Tier
existiert.
Ich hoffe, indem wir uns öffnen,
haben wir eine neue Phase
wissenschaftlicher Forschung,
in der diese Fragen
offen angegangen werden
statt durch den Filter
der Dogmen und Tabus.
(James) Ja, ich glaube,
die Welt ist bereit.
Ja, viele beschäftigen sich
mit Tierkommunikation.
Das ist fantastisch.
Das Wachsen und der Ausdruck davon
werden viel mehr
wahrgenommen werden.
Es sollte keinen Grund geben,
dass wir die Vögel
nicht von den Bäumen rufen können,
wenn man durch Tierkommunikation
wirklich eins ist.
Ich bin noch nicht so weit.
Ich übe mit meinen Pferden,
Hunden, Löwen, sogar mit Bären.
Je mehr Menschen wieder lernen,
in die Stille zu gehen
und ihre Gedanken anzuhalten,
desto friedlicher wird es.
Oder desto mehr wirkliche Impulse
erhalten wir.
Man sieht es auch
bei Hundebesitzern.
Wenn ein Besitzer lernt,
ganz zu sich zu kommen,
ganz zur Ruhe
und zum Frieden zu kommen,
spiegelt sich das
sofort im Tier wider.
Wenn wir wirklich lernen können,
Tiere als Wesen zu fragen,
was sie uns z.B. über die Umwelt-
und Naturprobleme zu sagen haben,
ob sie bereit sind, zu sterben
und gegessen zu werden ...
Ein Tier hat so viel Liebe.
Ein Tier kann sich auch hingeben.
Ein Tier gibt sich viel hin,
auch für die Menschen -
Hunde z.B., indem sie
mit Menschen zusammenleben wollen,
indem sie jemanden begleiten.
Tiere wollen auch von uns lernen.
Zumindest
habe ich das bisher so erfahren.
Sie sind so neugierig, zu lernen,
wie das mit den Menschen ist.
Sie beobachten ja die ganze Zeit.
Wenn man in den Zoo geht, beobachten
die Tiere uns genauso wie wir sie,
nur sind sie sehr oft frustriert,
weil sich der Mensch 1 Sek. nimmt -
klick - und weggeht.
Das Tier macht immer noch
die Verbindung, der Mensch geht weg
und erkennt gar nicht, dass man
in ein Gespräch kommen kann.
Wir sind so darauf konditioniert:
Tier, Schwanz, Fell, Ohren -
das war's.
Wir geraten gar nicht
in diese Verbindung und Ruhe.
Wenn wir das Potenzial dieser Wesen
nehmen können,
auch von Pflanzen -
die könnten uns auch viel sagen -,
wird das sehr spannend.
Ja. Mach Sitz.
Bina, nicht so gierig. Sitz.
Unsere gemeinsame Reise
hat uns eine tiefere Ebene
der Kommunikation zugänglich gemacht.
Ich nehme jetzt besser war, was Bina
und andere Tiere mir sagen wollen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020